on this episode chase visits me
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 154 of the last for me
ask gary vee show show tchau tchau
chase why don't you tell the Vayner
nation for i know many are gonna know
who you are as an in fact a lot of
people that watch this show discovered
me on when you hosted me instead of what
we're doing now me hosting you
why don't you really you know do a quick
little 90 second rapid who you are
Jodi Jodi photographer artist been that
my whole life about four years ago
started a company called creative live
with my friend Craig and now it's the
largest live streaming education company
the world incredible I am we reach
millions people all over the globe
that's my main focus right now still
making stuff but now trying to help
other people on the world make their
stuff in photography design filmmaking
make a life as an entrepreneur
where'd you throw up grew up in Seattle
parents you know super middle-class my
dad was a cop my mom was a administrator
no biotech company
no playing sports was conflicted as a
creative because I was also a jock and
those things didn't go together and then
that back then no it's there now it's
now now well from now creatives are
cooler than I mean being like a jock in
high school outside of like certain
parts that's a crazy at least on the
coasts now you're like in fifth place
yeah pretty interesting times but
actually I'd skip word culture helped me
put those two things together cuz super
creative and so I grew up as a skate
punk crumb and built a career that I why
don't we link up and I think in YouTube
oh no you have to control anyway let's
give some love to what the interview I
did with you why don't you want you to
tell everybody about that series and
what you do there because I think for
this specific this you're a part of a
doubleheader today well yes
first time ever yeah scary V show
doubleheader I just had my father-in-law
here different speed yes but uh but so I
think for our audio I was an old-school
marketer sure best dude that was a fun
episode super spot one day two in one
day and I'm putting him up the same time
you know like taping know like changings
got this I mean I've got meetings too
well
I got plenty but why don't you fill it I
think a lot of people enjoy it yeah what
you're the show you're doing is so
incredible and I think I want to siphon
as many people that watch this to make
sure they're watching your thing of
course
so sort of show about also five years
ago same time we started the creative
life called Chase Jarvis live actually I
turned down a bunch of network
opportunities to do you know they have
to be a lot of that kind of stuff
because they all didn't understand it
didn't want to do it right and the
economic economic bills suck [ __ ] so
Kerry duty be sure to [ __ ] get paid
didn't know nothing great the short
story too long already
just started producing it out of my
photo studio in Seattle inviting people
that I thought were great and doing cool
[ __ ] driving culture not just digital
culture but photographers filmmakers
guys like this turkey looks like matter
more adrian grenier from Entourage doing
interesting things and people you
they're super famous office people
you've never heard of who were just like
grinding away doing the cool [ __ ] so
just basically bringing creativity and
those folks to these I think my
interview is one of the great shows
there's just three of your show for sure
and I think the best yeah I would say
surprise you actually I think you polled
or you said you don't know I got
something from you yes people about you
know I think it's between this show or
in this show best interviews right you
were your best hundred-percent you and
the blaze will blaze right these ways
yeah uh-huh I think a lot of people
voted for the blaze I don't know who
this yeah we curse yeah that's our way
so I thought you were at your best on my
show yeah what's interesting about your
shower let's go I'm my fattest really
yeah is that why people don't like it
that's why they rated it second to the
blaze now the police he did a great job
I mean look it was applicable watching
yeah pick don't judge it for real it's
very very good it's nice but I've lost
27 pounds since then you look great
thanks man that's how wood that's what I
was Fisher readable I appreciate it yeah
India let's get into this show all right
let's do it India well
Malik listen he's a beast he gets on the
show a bunch chase Malik asked if I
pursue what I think is my passion
but don't come close to achieving what I
want well I've wasted my time
go chase you can ask it again yeah one
more time
Malik asked if I pursue what I think is
my passion but don't come close to
achieving what I want
well I've wasted my time no because
there's only there's really only one
thing in life which is doing exact what
you're sorry but which is doing exactly
what you're supposed to be doing and
that doesn't come from out here I lived
this exact problem I did what everybody
else wanted me to do for the first
chapter Martha I know who's that yeah
well who is that that was your parents
the world
yeah I agree the marketers Lamar can be
a doctor a lawyer or in some [ __ ] or
something else and yeah guys by the way
you were watching we're old
yeah back then doctor lawyer was like
yeah you're so smart doctor lawyer specs
what's the last time with 18 year old
that was like you hear me a doctor
lawyer that's like that's like she's
gonna run out of oh my god if it's
famous I mean that just took me there's
such a weird place like it was like you
should be a doctor or a lawyer that's
exact or an accountant your accountant
was an amazing those that was the list
these are my parents were amazingly
supportive this doesn't really come from
my parents but just like culturally
that's where your friend's parents went
son of a [ __ ] right that's the I [ __ ]
hate the friends parents counselor ever
four years high school no never was in a
different era
no disrespect is this folks I disrespect
different era different narrative that
being said I served somebody else for a
long time emotionally mentally even
trying to reconcile being an artist an
athlete that was because I was paying
attention of what culture wanted for me
but that's all [ __ ] there's only one
thing yeah you've got it I love ya
you're yeah there yeah there's only one
thing and that's you doing what you're
supposed to be doing in the world and
you can pay your dues I have a lot of
respect for working hard digging ditches
doing stuff to survive practicality you
call it but let's be real like you have
to do the thing that's in here otherwise
you're burnin use time I'm gonna I'm
gonna throw a different in addition yes
in addition you always say yes and
that's
yeah is that the improv things no but I
will say this that a countercultural mic
mic is just my fake name for general
people um self-awareness my big thing
more than anything is do not live on
regret so I definitely am also on team
being happy will always trump more money
at the end at the end at the end so I
try to play that way luckily for me mine
collided together but if you know you
and you know like money's like money
like money like you just are obsessed by
money then maybe you should do the thing
that makes you the most money because
you sit there one day it's a damn I wish
I was an artist now if you were the
other way that's like listening in here
and you have to be honest if what you
want to be is something yeah do you want
to be a needle point expert but you want
to make ten million dollars that's fake
those two things don't go together so
you've got to be real yeah I mean it's
self-awareness like a reverse engineer
yourself to not have regrets being
having regrets in your 70s 80s and 90s
is literally to me the worst thing that
could happen in life for sure
what'swhat's the Oscars name Malik bleep
seriously in here the answers are all in
here Jason Jason I will say this though
and this is something I've spent a lot
of time with the show on is we're not
really gonna go here yes you I do
believe that you and I got lucky by
having self-awareness and into like
emotional intelligence isn't you know
what it's serious well for sure it's by
the way it's always been the black it's
just being put front and center um I
just want to make sure we're giving
practical advice saying like follow from
what's in here I have family members who
literally have no [ __ ] idea what's in
here yeah I know them cold so they have
no idea that's actually thing one is you
gotta figure it out and the way you
figure out is to live your life and get
in adventures and do sup yeah you know
what I'm so on that test and learn
between 20 and 30 to me is hot I'm
hotter this idea that if you really want
to live the best life you can live the
new game plan is from 20 to 30 test a
lot of things because the downside the
risk is you could go risky and and the
it's you've got bigger upside than
downside classic yeah Richard Branson
litigate the downside and that's
literally what cradle exists so you can
take thousands of classes from the
world's best people and you can
literally dabble and it's not just that
one to Community College you're taking
it from like Pilger Prize winner New
York Times bestsellers yeah this guy
like smart smart people your hands dirty
but we're gonna be over seventeen hours
ago India yeah Alan do you know AJ's
name is Alan Jack yeah call EJ Alan two
L's
in third grade he said he was Alan and
third rating just said call me Alan that
lasted for a couple months it's back to
AJ good Alan asked when you rather time
travel a hundred years into the past or
a hundred years into the future and why
passed I would make so much [ __ ] Bank
i buy the judgment i buy the jet for
$10,000 in 1963 and i'd be good oh my
[ __ ] money India because you know
everything
not even close name it what oh you
didn't mean that Alan would got it well
I tripped you I said with what you know
now you said yes get out of here I know
you [ __ ] all right let's let's take
a step back if you don't know anything
and you land and you don't know anything
and you didn't know that you did that
yeah I would go to the future only
because I right now as a human know what
happened over the last hundred years and
the upside is not knowing I put my
answer through the exact same filter if
you know everything I go backwards so
you can do some really harsh it don't
know anything go forward like send me to
the future I mean I'd be like this
Microsoft company feels right I like
this governor in Arkansas I bet you he's
gonna be President I would just kill it
people be like Nostradamus I mean
crushing Vlad ass dear Gary in episode
122 you say it 22 to 24 don't settle
what is the settling age I thought you
should never settle that's so weird
that's so funny from something yes yes
what's interesting is we just talked
about it though how I
just said from 20 to 30 that's funny
that's interesting timing look I think I
think first of all I think every goddamn
answer on this show has to be very
personal meaning if you and your
boyfriend or girlfriend have a baby when
your votes 17 because that's what
happened in your life
practicality enters your world that's
exact right so you know practicality
comes a knock and say yo sup man
practicality here right cuz you're a
different seventeen year old because you
have a child coming something you gotta
know you got the razor so for every
single person that's watching
I think practicality or settling because
they're cousins it on to be the exact
same thing but there's cousins in them
comes at different times
I do think look I know a lot of 40 to 50
year olds that are still living in outer
space and dreaming and I think there's
diminishing returns at some level around
that especially if it hasn't happened
already unless for happy let's drop it
isn't there's a practicality the thing
you dip into because you can be living
your dream you can be pretending living
in Fantasyland but you got to pay rent
you got to eat and sometimes that
actually dip into real life is what
motivates your passion like those two
things they I feel like well that's
that's Casey's favorite answer right I
don't think I was talking about Casey's
favorite answer and I think he said in
the show was do something you hate to
realize how much you want to do
something else go wash dishes it's like
he does you'll be motivating oh yeah
what's your thing you did the most in
your life what's the thing you did the
most that you hated I went to school for
[ __ ] here from 6 to 18 I hated like I
mean that's why I love it so much now
I'm not in [ __ ] English class
seriously like we got to put a filter on
this culturally like there this is a
real thing that people are going to
college for all the wrong reasons
do you need a piece of paper that says
you have to have a piece of paper to cut
someone open
I want my doctor to be sort of certified
I want my airline pilot to be certified
anything else why or maybe there's some
value there or if you're exploring if
you're trying to figure your [ __ ] out
school is a reasonable thing but I the
average person graduates college at
35,000 tour
that's the average so for everybody who
graduates with the only 10 grand there's
some of your graduates with 50 that's
[ __ ] preaching yeah that's I've been
pumping out some serious content around
this issue so the answer is it's
different for everybody
some people get practical at 16 you know
they don't have that risk tolerance
which I figure it out there's a
practicality when you figure out what
you want to do they're gonna get to work
you call that practical yeah look here's
what I truly think I think [ __ ] is
really hitting the fan I think the
Internet I don't know if you heard of it
but obviously have all of us have it's
only 20 years old I know it's been
around for a long time I know there's
nerds that's a man and I know I mean in
Windows 95 came out normal people
started going on the Internet
we are 20 years under this thing this
thing is fundamentally the biggest
cultural shift of our time for sure
they've changed everything we're just
starting and all the rules need to be
thought about in a very aggressive way
because there's so many alternatives for
the way that we always thought the
amount of people that go to college
because that's what their parents want
because their parents were sold on the
propaganda of college before that
literally about their ego most like that
I believe that son one to this yeah yep
I made a shirt called schmarvard that is
like literally my number one selling
t-shirts not clothes India
sorry that's good you Sean asked would
you say the tea and timing is way more
important than the tea and talent
not even close for me yes No
it's show me do not disrespect this show
the show know timing is timing is a
talent in itself for sure like everybody
thinks like serendipity like yeah in
2006 after carefully watching YouTube
for five months I just got lucky I
decided to go on it you know lucky
timing for me a weird let me no no no
there was talented and understanding
that this platform was gonna be
meaningful that that's why I got I got
right here you got so lucky with your
timing with you - [ __ ] [ __ ]
I [ __ ] paid attention yeah it's going
there I there was talent in
understanding that this was going to be
important and I put time and effort to
learn it it wasn't luck a little weird
here I am Oh weird here's YouTube that's
it's not timing is a talent in itself
that one of the most important time
talents Chase for sure I mean I really
think I'd told Isham that's like this
issue is yes um
Allen cultivated what are you good at
what do you love
that's what matters timing I mean sure I
guess it matters in the sake of getting
hit by a bus yeah too many people think
you were at the right place at the right
time let me tell you something ischium
and everybody else if the internet
didn't come along I would have 17,000
liquor stores right now what have been
great timing for bricks and mortar like
talent Trump's all it is the absolute
variable period that historic fireworks
in there yeah listen yes yes I love the
hustle yeah I love the hustle talent
yeah town without hard work is pretty
much yes but but talent is but I do
think tellers a variable timing it's not
even a close I cannot even miss yeah
timing what you're but I will say this
if I work sixth if I work 16 hours a day
if I work 16 hours a day on my
basketball game I am NOT going to be an
NBA pleasure talent is the bearable what
hard work does is it maximizes that
palette of whatever you deploy that hard
work against the initial basket that way
I argue in that rant that's the question
he's after it transfer very nicely
trying to save ish him but that question
timing is a talent guys timing is a
talent itself somebody's to be like Oh
Gary you were so lucky with the timing
virtual reality and 360 vo no no no no I
had talented figuring out that this is
about to be the time for that thing to
pop I think what's going on with you
guys in 360 video I mean 360 [ __ ]
video I know it's we're playing around
you can imagine being in Miami where you
look around and see everything that's
educational that's next that's next
level India yeah it's one to five yeah 5
Corey asked Star Wars or Star Trek we're
both Star Wars not Star Trek Star Wars
not Star Trek - how old are you I'm 43
yeah
and I'm 39 and like that's like the
golden era for like if if you were 52 if
we have Peter he might have been Star
Trek and Star Trek was earlier there's
not a lot of there's not a lot of 32 to
40 year old Star Trek oh there's a funny
pocket of maybe 35 to 42 because there
is a funny pocket of like 30 to 35 order
Star Trek The Next Generation during a
lull of Star Wars where it popped a
little bit but my intuition is that
actually quick side question of the day
get in there Star Trek or Star Wars and
your age I think people realize that I
think Star Trek is really I think Star
Trek is 48 and above and then a weird
little pocket of 32 32 yeah and there's
a couple of like people who are yeah
yeah cultural thing but Star Wars Star
Wars I don't I don't freak out you don't
have any Game of Thrones like yeah
there's some Star Wars really Star Wars
is the only thing I go for like I'll go
see Star Wars opening night for sure
because that's a cultural it and for me
it was a big thing because it's hat like
the Jets Star Wars these were some of
the few pillars that made me an American
when I first came all of this art was
actually figure and all their guns you
slamming yeah they're worth some money
no they're not send them to me Star Wars
chase yeah you get the floor for the
last couple seconds one little rant and
then the question of the day you get to
ask the vaynernation any question
they'll leave comments I would I would
really think about using this as a focus
group do your thing nope I cannot help
you
no on a spot I'm enjoying this
tremendously good yeah look it was very
similar so so keep stops to linking and
ask the questions no me I know everybody
chasing here I know everybody who you're
very emotional chase do you know I think
I'm all-time all-time like 11 no no no
no no I yes
in that context I actually in my will
have put that when humans figure out how
to measure EQ I want to be dug up and
tested because I truly think I'm all
time yeah good I think I think you score
very high all time
what you're asking me to do is ask the
vaynernation a question that I want to
use basically use them as a folks you
don't have to do anything you want I
just at this point want you have any
[ __ ] question that's our gonna win
the World Series I mean like come up
with something what's their favorite
color I don't give a [ __ ] at this point
talk to me about so this is about
virtual reality okay what I want to know
about virtual reality is how likely do
you think it is that it will change the
game in the next 24 months is it going
to be everywhere in the next 24 months
or is it like so many things that they
thought were gonna happen and vidiq this
is gonna get just punted I think they
connect it home everyone oh yeah by the
year 2010 yeah all that [ __ ] got punted
way downfield so what about virtual
reality is it happening now or that's a
great question because I talk a lot
about timing and practicality around
when these things pop we know what's
gonna happen but is it 24 months or less
or is this more like a 7 years from now
it's really gonna happen there you go
Jenni Jeff thanks for me on the show Mia
that's for something success very much
by people you keep asking questions
we'll keep answering
[Music]